[موسيقى]
جزاء الغيم تنهمر الحروف لها نغم يحس به
الشغوف
يرى فيها غصونا باسقات
على اطرافها تدنو القطوف
[موسيقى]
فان لبثت مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
كان ابو حيان توحيدي يقول لقد اشكل
الانسان على الانسان وكان من دعائه اللهم
اوضحنا لنا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى في سوره الاعراف ياتوك
بكل ساحر عليم وفي سوره الشعراء ياتوك بكل
سحار عليم ما الفرق بين سحار وساحر يقول
الالوسي في التفريق بين سحار وساحر في طرق
عديده منها ان السحاره بصيغه المبالغه
يكون لمن يريد السحر والساحر بصيغه اسم
الفاعل يكون لمن سحر في وقت دون وقت اشار
الزمخشري لسبب تخصيص كل صيغه في تركيبها
بان قوم فرعون ردوا على قوله ان هذا لساحر
عليم بقولهم ياتوك بكل سحار عليم فجاؤوا
بصيغه المبالغه ليطمنوا فرعون ويسكن بعض
قلقه واما في الاعراف فجاء قوله تعالى
يريد ان يخرجكم من ارضكم فماذا تامرون ولم
يذكر السحر اي لم يقل يريد ان يخرجكم من
ارضكم بسحره فناسب ذلك مجيء لفظه ساحر
ذكر ان رجلا من بني زبيد قدم مكه في
الجاهليه ومعه تجاره فاشتراها منه رجل من
بني سهم
فنقلها الى بيته ثم تغيب ثم ابتغاها
الزبيدي فحبسها عنه فجاء الى بني سهم
يستعديهم عليه فاغلظوا له فعرف الا سبيل
الى ماله فطوف في بطون قريش يستعين بهم
فتخاذلوا عنه فلما راى ذلك اشرف على جبل
ابي قبيس حين اخذت قريش مجالسها وجعل ينشد
يا ال فهر لمظلوم بضاعته ببطن مكهناء
الدار والنفر واشعث محرما لم يقضي حرمته
بين المقام وبين الركن والحجر قائم من بني
سهم بذمتهم ام ذاهب في ضلال مال معتمري
فلما نزل اعظمت قريش ذلك وقال ناس منهم
تعالوا فلنكن حلفا فضولا دون المكيين
والاحلاف فاجتمعوا في دار عبد الله بن
جدعان وصنع لهم طعاما عظيما ليجتمع بنو
هاشم وبنو اسد وبنو زهره وبنو تيم
وتحالفوا على ان لا يظلم بمكه غريب ولا حر
ولا عبد الا كانوا معه حتى ياخذوا له بحقه
ويؤد اليه مظلمته من انفسهم ومن غيرهم
ثم عبدوا الى ماء زمزم فجعلوه في جفنه ثم
بعثوا به الى البيت المعظم فغسلت به
اركانه ثم اتوا به
فشربوه وقد كان رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم يومئذ قبل ان يوحى اليه
روت عائشه ام المؤمنين رضي الله عنها انها
سمعت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
لقد شهدت في دار عبد الله بن جدعان حلف
الفضول اما لو دعيت اليه اليوم الاجبت وما
احب ان لي به حمرا نعم واني نقضته
وحمر النعم هي الابل الحمراء وهي اكرم
الابل واعلاها منزله ويضرب بها المثل في
النفائس
حلف الفضول هو حلف رد المظالم والظلم
ظلمات وخليق بكل مكان
يرعى ذمه الله في عباده ان يكون فيه حلف
فضول ياخذ للمظلوم حقه من الظالم
[موسيقى]
احيانا تاتي لتجلس في مكان فيقال لك ان
فلان جالس هنا فاختر لنفسك مكانا اخر او
تجلس على طاوله مثلا في مقهى او في مطعم
فيقال لك ان هذه الطاوله محجوزه وعليك ان
تختار غيرها
روي عن الطفيله الغنوي انه قال ولا اقول
لجار البيت يتبعني نفس محلك ان الجو محلول
وقوله نفس يعني به هنا ابعد ووسع المكان
بيني وبينك وقوله الجو المراد به الارض
المتسعه البارزه وليس المراد الهواء بيت
الشعر هذا يؤكد على خلق كريم وهو مراعاه
حق الجار
ولين الجانب له فالطفيل ينفي عن نفسه صفه
الملاله تصريحا وتلميحا من الجار الذي
يرتحل بارتحاله ويحل بحلوله اذ في قوله ان
الجو محلول اي منزول فيه تلميح لعدم
الرغبه في الجوار
[موسيقى]
هذه بدائل عربيه لكلمات غير عربيه اشتهرت
على السنه الناس
التلفون بديلها هاتف والجاكيت بديلها رداء
او ستره وكلمه سيرفس بديلها العربي خدمه
وكلمه مودرن بديلها العربي حديث او عصري
هذا طبعا من اجل ان لا نبتعد عن لغتنا
[موسيقى]
يقول بعض العوام اذا رغب في شيء رغبه
شديده ولا يزال لم يظهر به انا ميت عليه
ولذلك اصلا فصيح في العربيه فقد روي عن
المجنون انه قال اذا وعدت زاد الهوى
الانتظارها وان بخلت بالوعد مت على الوعد
[موسيقى]
زار علي بن عبيده الريحاني جاريه كان
يهواها عند اخوانه فحان وقت الظهر فبادر
الجماعه الصلاه وعلي يحدث الجاريه حتى
كادت الصلاه تفوت فقيل يا ابا الحسن
الصلاه فقال رويدك حتى تزول الشمس اي حتى
تقوم الجاريه وهذا من زندقه العشاق
مجازا طبعا
[موسيقى]
كان الامام احمد بن حنبل في صحبه احد
الحكماء والعلماء ويدعى حاتم الاصم فساله
يا حاتم هل لك ان تخبرني كيف السبيل الى
السلامه من الناس فنظر الاصم اليه وقال
تعطيهم من مالك ولا تاخذوا من مالهم
يؤذونك ولا تؤذيهم وتقضي مصالحهم ولا
تكلفهم قضاء مصالحك فرد عليه احمد بن حنبل
انها والله صعبه يا حاتم فاضاف الاصم
وليتك تسلم منهم
[موسيقى]
سالتكم في تويتر عن اكذب مقوله يتداولها
الناس في ايامهم وفيما لاستعرض معكم بعض
ما وصلني من مشاركاتكم هذه مشاركه من نوار
تقول الزمن بنفسي ويبدو ان الزمن لم ينسى
عبد السلام يقول احنا زارنا النبي عليه
الصلاه والسلام طبعا هذه من الاشياء التي
يعني يقولونها مجامله للضيف عندما يدخل
الضيف يقولون يا مرحبا والله احنا زهرنا
النبي
عبد السلام يقول ان هذه من اكذب المقولات
ايضا
احمد مشاري يقول مسافه الطريق
وكم من الاصدقاء يقول لك مسافه الطريق
وبعدين يجيك بعد اربع ساعات يعني لو حدثكم
والله عن بعد اصدقائي لحتى يعني تشيب لها
نواصل الولدان
ابراهيم جاب الله يقول عيب اني طيب بزياده
يجيك واحد مقطع السبع بحور
ينطبق عليها مثلا يابا تحت السواهب في
دواهي وبعدين يقول عن نفسه عيب
وهدى الانصاري تقول الرجل ما يعيبه الا
جيبه هذه من الاكذب الكذبات فعلا الرجل
يعيبه بقله الاخلاق ويعيبه البخل ويعيبه
الظلم ويعيبه الفجور عيبه اشياء كثيره
وكذلك المراه
ولكن هذه من المقولات الكاذبه
ملك يقول او تقول اعمل خيرا شرا تلقى وهذا
ايضا من الاشياء بالعكس اعمل خيرا تلقى
خيرا وتلقى سترا وصنائع المعروف تقي مصارع
السوء
وحازم حريري يقول الاختلاف في الراي لا
يفسد للود قضيه هذا من اكذب ما سمعت فعلا
يعني بتلاقي الناس في الاتجاه المعاكس
يضربون بعض كم مره شفنا الناس تضرب بعضها
في اختلاف الراي
تحيه طبعا للزميل فيصل القاسم
فر يقول بعيد عن العين بعيد عن القلب
وفعلا بعض الناس مهما
ابتعدوا وبعدتم ولم يبعد عن القلب حكم
وغبتم وانتم في الفؤاد حضور
وان كون يقول اعتبر الموضوع منتهي وهذا
يذكرني بذلك الذي قال عن صديقه لا اعرف
منه الا ضرب الصدر وضرب الجبهه يقول اذا
جئته اطلب منه شيئا يقول اعتبر الموضوع
منتهي يدق على صدره ثم اذا استنجزته ضرب
على جبهته وقال نسيت
اعتبر الموضوع منتهي اذا بهذا اصل معكم
الى ختام هذه الفقره وشكرا لكم على هذه
المشاركات الجميله
[موسيقى]
اتفق الرواه على ان الاخطل وجرير والفرزدق
كانوا الثلاثي الرائد شعريا في العصر
الاموي وحديثنا اليوم عن الاخطل
مسيحي من قبيله تغلب الشهيره جعله عبد
الملك بن مروان واحدا من شعراء البلاط
الاموي كتب رائيتين تعتبران من عيون الشعر
العربي يقول في مطلع الاولى التي يهجوا
فيها القبائل القيسيه الا يسلم يا هند هند
بني بدري وان كان حيانا ناعدا اخر الدهر
وان كنت قد اصميتني اذ رميتني بسهمك فرام
يصيد ولا يدري اسيله مجرى الدمع اما
وشاحها فيجري واما الحجل منها فلا يجري
وثم رائيه ثانيه تاتيكم بعد دقيقتين
ولد غياث ابن غوث بنصلط ويكنى ابا مالك في
الحيره في العام التاسع عشر للهجره
الموافق عام 640 للميلاد نشا على المسيحيه
وقد عاش في دمشق ردحا من الزمن واقام حينا
اخرى في منطقه الجزيره السوريه لقب
بالاخطل ولذلك اللقب قصص كثيره منها انه
لقب اطلقه عليه شاعر بني تغلب كعب بن جعيل
حينما قال له انك لاخطل يا غلام وذلك لطول
اذنيه ورخاوتهما في اهانه له وجاء في لسان
العرب انه سمي بالاخطل لخطل لسانه اي طوله
وقيل انه كني بذلك لفحش كلامه اما ابو
الفرج الاصفهاني فقد اورد في الاغاني نقلا
عن ابن السكيت بان الاخطل قد هجا رجلا من
قبيلته فقال له يا غلام
انك الاخطل فلقب به
قيل فيه الكثير فوصفه الفرزدق حينما سئل
عن اشعر الناس قائلا كفاءك بي اذا افتخرت
وبجرير اذا هجا وببن النصرانيه اذا امتدح
ويعني الاخطل فيما قال عنه ابو عمرو ابن
العلاء لو ادرك الاخطل يوما واحدا من
الجاهليه ما فضلت عليه احدا اما جرير وهو
يشكل معه ومع الفرزدق ثلاثي الشعر الاموي
فيقول ابن النصرانيه ارمان للفرائص
وامدحنا للملوك واوصفنا للخمر والحمر
والحمر يعني النساء
قرض الاخطل الشعر صغيرا وعرف به عرف
الشهره حينما اتصل به يزيد ابن معاويه
وكان ولي عهد والده معاويه بن ابي سفيان
كان عبد الرحمن بن حسان الانصاري قد شبب
برمله بنت معاويه اختي يزيد فغضب يزيد
وامر كعب بن جعيل ان لا يهجم عبد الرحمن
الانصاري فحسب بل بهجاء قبيلته باكملها
ولكن كعبا خاف من هجاء قوم ناصروا رسول
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
فاشار على يزيد بن معاويه بانه اذا كان لا
يستطيع هجائهم فهو يعرف من يستطيع ان
يهجوهم دون ان يرعى فيهم الا ولا ذمه
فكان ذلك الاخطل اجل اخطل الانصار هجاء
لادعا قاسيا واستخدم الاسلوبا والفاظا
قللت من شانهم وضرب على وتر حساس لدى
العرب فجعلهم دون قريش مكانه وشرفا مشيرا
الى ما بين العدنانيه والقحطانيه من عداء
تاريخي
ذهبت قريش بالمكارم والعلا
واللؤم تحت عمائم الانصار فذروا المكارم
لستم من اهلها وخذوا مساحيكم بني النجار
قربت تلك الحادثه الاخطل من البلاط الاموي
وكانت مقدمه للاتصال بالامويين فحصل منهم
على المال والجاه والشهره وعاش متكسبا من
تلك العلاقه ثم اصبح الاخطل شاعر الامويين
والناطق الرسمي باسمهم والمروج لسياساتهم
والمدافعه عنها وفيهم يقول
تمت جدودهم والله فضلهم وجد قوما سواهم
خامل نكد ويوم صفين والابصار خاشعه
امدهم اذ دعوا من ربهم مددوا وانتم اهل
بيت لا يوازنهم بيت اذا عدت الاحساب
والعدد
عرف الاخطل بقصائد هجائيه جمعته مع جرير
فهجا كلاهما الاخر يقول جرير قبح الاله
وجوه تغلب انها هانت علي مراسلا وسبالا
قبح الاله وجوه تغلب كلما شبح الحجيج
وكبروه اهلاالا عبدوا الصليب وكذبوا بمحمد
وبجبرائيل وكذبوا ميكالا
فما كان من الاخطل الا ان رد عليه بالنمط
عينه في قصيده قال بعدها جرير ان الاخطل
قد غلبه فيها
يقول كذبتك عينك ان رايت بواسط غلس الظلام
من الرباب خيالا
فنعق بطقنك يا جرير فانما من نتك نفسك في
الخلائق ضلاله من نتك نفسك ان تسامي دارما
او ان توازن حاجبا وعقالا واذا وضعت اباك
في ميزانهم قفزت حديدته الي كفشاالى
واذا وضعت اباك في ميزانهم قفزت حديدته
اليه كفشانا
[موسيقى]
تمر علينا الحوادث فنغضب ونحزن ونفرح
ونخاف
وتستطهار القلوب ولكن الحقيقه ان هذا
اليوم سيمضي مثل ما مضى امس ومثل ما مضت
الايام بحلولها ومرها نستخلص من الموقف
العبره تبقى العبره وتمضي المواقف الذين
يرتابون بالايام
ويترقبون القادم يبيعون ما يعلمون بما لا
يعلمون ولو تحدثنا الى اهل القبور
لاخبرونا عن مواقف كثيره عاشوها ثم مضوا
وذهبوا فكان لم تكن وكان لم يكونوا
اقول في ذلك
تمر للحادثات على اناس فتنخلع القلوب من
الصدور ولو علموا نواميس الليالي
لاسعفهم صدى من في القبور حوادث امس ذكر
اليوم غابت وظل الفكر في طي السطور السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]